und unser Kollege Peter Thiede hat für
uns über den Krieg berichtet aus
Russland er war in Moskau und hat dort
immer berichtet für Bild war im Einsatz
und jetzt wird ihm allerdings die
Einreise nach Russland verwehrt trotz
gültigen arbeitsvisums wir begrüßen
Ihnen hier bei uns im Studio schönen
guten Tag Peter Thiede guten Morgen
man kann sagen du bist die ja
personifizierte Gefahr für Russlands
innere Sicherheit oder also zumindest
ist dass sie lächerliche Begründung die
mir am Flughafen gegeben worden ist am
ich bin am Montagabend nach Moskau
gereist am Flughafen Luca wo war das wie
üblich man sieht hier damals war ich wo
war ich da da war ich sogar ein Moskau
am Flughafen Nuka hat man mir die
einreisefahrt verwehrt ist es immer so
gewesen in den letzten Monaten das immer
nicht eingereist bin gab es ein kurzes
Verhör bei der Ausreise gab es ein paar
höher und immer so nachgefragt und auch
dieses Mal war es so dass ich da
mitgenommen worden bin und diesmal
allerdings schon nach einer Stunde kam
jemand an und hat mir dann mitgeteilt
dass ich ein Einreiseverbot habe und
zwar gleich zwei Stück und das ist ein
absolutes Novum was da passiert ist
nämlich mir ist dann erklärt worden ich
sei
dass man den Paragraphen anwendet
Gefährdung öffentliche Sicherheit und
Ordnung und dann ist mir später erklärt
worden dass es einen Vermerk des
Geheimdienstes FSB gibt wonach ich eine
Gefährdung für die
Verteidigungsfähigkeit der Russischen
Föderation bin das ist so albern und
daran sieht man wie nervös dieses System
ist aber das ist etwas das ist bisher
nur angewendet worden für russische
Oppositionelle für Alexander valny für
für Michael rollokowski und dafür andere
um dir in der Einreise zu hindern da
werden dann immer zwei verschiedene
Paragraphen gilt genommen da muss man
zweimal zum Gericht gehen das dauert und
falls man dann zwei Richter findet die
so eine Verfügung aufheben dann hat er
Geheimdienst halt genügend Zeit um einen
dritten Grund zu erfinden und das hat
man jetzt bei mir an angewandt und die
Gefahr ist jetzt das dass der Anfang war
und das ist eine Repressionswelle für
gegen die Kollegen gibt die in Russland
Arbeiten von von den deutschen Medien
aber auch von allen westlichen Medien
das ist die Befürchtung die man zum
Beispiel diplomatischen Kreisen hat ich
habe ja dann noch die Nacht
durchtelefoniert auch mit der deutschen
Botschaft und mit anderen und die gehen
davon aus dass das nur der Anfang ist du
hast von Anfang an über den Krieg
berichtet live aus Moskau so sah das in
den letzten Wochen und Monaten aus
wir wollen nach Moskau schauen zu
unserem Kollegen Peter Thiede ist schon
bei uns zu unseren Kollegen Peter Tide
nach Moskau Peter Tide für uns aus
Moskau zugeschaltet er ist der Mann vor
dem der Kreml zittert bildchef Reporter
Peter Thiede von Anfang an ist er dabei
deswegen auch solche Angriffe wie die
auf das Kernkraftwerk heute Nacht das
soll Angst und Schrecken verbreiten es
ist ganz eindeutig das Ziel das sagen
wirklich zwei verschiedene
Nachrichtendienste er bleibt während
andere Journalisten das Land verlassen
als einer der letzten internationalen
Reporter berichtet er für Bild aus
Russland filmt Welt exklusiv die
russische Invasion zeigt den Russen den
Krieg wir gehen mal ganz kurz rüber weil
wir sind natürlich hier weiter im
Grenzgebiet unterwegs und wir sehen wie
ein Panzer abgeladen wird unmittelbar
also anderthalb Kilometer vor der Grenze
zu Russland in dem gesamten Gebiet auf
der gesamten Länge die wir hier abfahren
wir stehen am Kaufhaus GUM und am Roten
Platz und man sieht hier dass wir
überall Familien unterwegs sind mit den
Kindern
und
man selber Vater ist zerreißt es einem
das Herz wenn man diesen Widerspruch
sieht Peter Thiede Beobachter und
Bericht Erstatter historischer
Ereignisse etwa Putins propaganda-show
im Moskauer Olympiastadion Ende März die
zu einem medialen Supergau wird wegen
einer Panne im Staatsfernsehen
Moskau zu unserem Korrespondenten Peter
Tide der direkt vor dem Stadion war als
es passierte Peter wie glaubwürdig ist
ein Serverausfall wie viel Angst hat der
Kreml vor Peter Tide wie sehr zittert
der russische Machtapparat vor dem Bild
Chef Reporter und vor allem ist das der
Beginn für weitere Repressionen gegen
westliche Journalisten
[Musik]
und die Gefahr für Russland steht nach
wie vor bei uns im Studio Peter Thiede
also du darfst nicht mehr einreisen du
bist eine Gefahr für das Land trotz
gültigem Visums ist das das Ende der
Pressefreiheit also es gibt keine
Pressefreiheit in Russland die gab es in
den letzten 20 Jahren nicht die ist
jetzt noch weniger da das ist und es ist
damit bin nicht nur ich gemeint also das
klingt immer so lächerlich und das ist
eigentlich auch komplett lächerlich mich
als Gefahr für die innere Sicherheit
Russland anzusehen aber man sieht wie
sehr gefürchtet wird dass er seine
unabhängige freie Berichterstattung aus
Russland gibt das gezeigt wird was in
Russland tatsächlich los ist wie die
Wirtschaft tatsächlich wirkt weil die
russische Propaganda arbeitet in
Deutschland auch über deutsche Politiker
und auch über einige deutsche
Journalisten wirklich daran an der
Legende dass die Wirtschaftssanktionen
gegen Russland nicht wirken würden
wladimir Putin hat eine Heidenangst
davor dass wir heile durch diesen Winter
kommen und er und sein Land im Frühjahr
zusammenbricht die haben eine
Arbeitslosigkeit die wird noch versteckt
die ist gigantisch im gesamten
Tourismus-Sektor hat niemand mehr Arbeit
wenn man jetzt hinfährt und zeigen würde
wie die sank tatsächlich wirken das
ganze Fabriken leer sind das ganze Leute
nur nach scheinen beschäftigt sind dass
sich das System das nicht mehr lange
leisten kann davor zittert man und man
zittert nicht von mir man zittert vor
der Freien Presse man zittert vor den
Kollegen die noch vor Ort sind und von
denen die rein wollen und ich bin jetzt
der Anfang und das ist wirklich das muss
man einem einmal sagen das ist ein Novum
das ist noch nicht passiert dass ein
Journalist ein westlicher Journalist mit
einem gültigen Visum Journalisten Visum
abgewiesen worden ist und an der Arbeit
so gehindert wird was bedeutet das für
die Menschen gerade auch für die
Menschen in Russland auch für die
Menschen in Russland ist das irgendwie
relativ egal weil die Leben mit diesen
Verhältnissen und ganz ehrlich die Masse
der Russen interessiert sich auch nicht
dafür und man kann und man muss es auch
so deutlich sagen wer in Russland an
Informationen kommen will kann an die
Informationen kommen die meisten Russen
wollen es schlicht und ergreifend nicht
das ist eine kriegsnation die sind
Gehirn gewaschen oder nicht folgt die
Masse immer noch Wladimir Putin und die
meisten der Leute die wir jetzt sehen
die jetzt aus dem Land rausströmen es
sind ja wirklich Männer Kohorten die
sich jetzt aufmachen die in Georgien an
der Grenze stehen die sich auf dem
Landweg über die Mongolei rausmachen da
wird nicht kontrolliert die nach
Finnland wollen die nach Estland wollen
die auf jedem verfügbaren Weg raus
wollen mein Flieger zurück aus Moskau
war voll mit russischen Männern die 3000
Euro gezahlt haben für ein Flugticket
das sind aber alles Leute die haben sich
vorher für den Krieg nicht interessiert
jeweils in der großen Masse ich kenne
auch andere aber die Masse hat sich für
den Krieg nicht interessiert es
interessiert sie erst wenn es Sie
persönlich betrifft die Ukraine sind den
egal ihre Nachbarn sind illegal aber sie
selber wollen nicht in den Krieg jetzt
flüchten sie das wird zum Problem für
Wladimir Putin aber für die Russen
bedeutet das jetzt gar nichts
die können die Informationen haben sie
wollen sie nicht haben in der Masse und
die Leute die kritisch sind ohnehin
schon weg wie geht es jetzt seiner
Meinung nach weiter es wird wladimir
Putin hat ein massives Problem weil
dadurch dass er jetzt quasi auch die
Leute die hinter ihm im standen die
männliche Bevölkerung in Angst und
schreckenfall versetzt
wankt seine Machtbasis aber sein Problem
liegt nicht in Russland sein Problem
liegt in Peking es ist ein
Generalstabschef patruschef ist vor
Tagen nach Peking gereist um in Peking
zu gucken dass man ein Militärtechnik
kommt die Russen kriegen die Verluste
die sie vorne an Material in der Ukraine
haben nicht nachproduziert die Panzer
die Sie dort täglich verlieren können
sie nicht täglich nachproduzieren selbst
die gigantische russische
Rüstungsindustrie schafft es nicht die
Verluste auszugleichen deswegen ist
patruschef jetzt nach Peking geflogen
und hat versucht militärunterstützung
aus Peking zu bekommen und die ist ihm
nach allem was wir gehört haben verwehrt
worden und das ist ein Problem wenn
Wladimir Putin den Rückhalt von Peking
verliert dann hat er ein echtes Problem
da muss er gucken wie er jetzt da aus
dem Schlamassel rauskommt deswegen nach
meiner Einschätzung auch diese
unglaublich schnellen Referenten die hat
er ja angeordnet kurz nachdem er aus von
von einem Treffen aus der markant
zurückkam wo halt China mit er dabei war
wo er sich mit Präsident Ski getroffen
hat und er wird jetzt versucht er muss
jetzt versuchen da irgendwie Linien zu
ziehen in der Ukraine deswegen erklärt
er jetzt ukrainisches Gebiet zu
russischer Erde das wird er in dieser
Woche machen wie Paul das gesagt hat und
dann wird ihr das Verteidigen er wird
jeden jede Kugel die auf diese Gebiete
geschossen wird aus der Ukraine wird
erwerten als Angriff auf russische Erde
ob er noch mehr kann wage ich zu
bezweifeln seine Machtbasis im Gremmel
ist am Bröckeln nicht so dramatisch dass
es ihn schon wegspült und dann ist er
ganz offensichtlich auch schwerstkrank
wir haben die Berichte dass er in einer
Dacia jetzt die Zeit verbracht hat es
gibt ernstzunehmende Hinweise
tatsächlich diesmal erstmals ernst zu
nehmende Hinweise darauf dass Wladimir
Putin sich einer intensiven
medizinischen Behandlung in den letzten
Wochen unterzogen hat in der vorigen
Woche sollte es eine Fernsehansprache
abends von Wladimir Putin geben eine
angekündigte Ansprache die ist
verschoben worden dann auf die nächsten
Monat einfach nicht stattgefunden das
ist ein deutliches Zeichen dafür dass
irgendetwas nicht stimmt und zwar das
mit Wladimir Putin etwas nicht stimmt
die Gefahr ist das werden wir Putin so
krank ist dass es ihm alles jetzt egal
ist
sagte Bild Chef Reporter Peter Thiede
der aktuell nicht mehr nach Russland
einreisen darf 900 Tage trotz eines
gültigen arbeitsvisums herzlichen Dank
[Musik]